one of your biggest hits
um was I'll always love you you did
write that do you remember the first
time you heard Whitney's version yes
because I grew up hearing yours and then
all of a sudden The Bodyguard happened
I'm just curious what was your first
because it's your baby there's a little
story about that when they were doing
The Bodyguard movie yeah they had chosen
another song for the theme song and
someone came out with that very song
right when they were about to put the
movie out and they were they were
drastic I mean they were really trying
to find a great song and Kevin Costner
and his secretary they said do you
remember Dolly Parton's song of I will
always love you as a country song but
it's a beautiful song and so they called
me to see if they could use it and I
said yes and I didn't hear anything else
about it I didn't know if they had it I
didn't know if they had done it and I
was driving my car from downtown where
my office was on 16th Avenue back to my
house over in Brentwood and I was just
driving along and and I had the radio on
and I just heard this it uh
should stay you know that yeah it's you
know it's one of those things like it's
like a dog here yeah you know I know
what is that and all of a sudden that's
the first and that's the first time they
hadn't sent it to me they did nothing I
heard it on the radio and so when it
went into and uh yeah and it's like I
just freaked out I had to pull over to
the side because I honestly thought I
was going to wreck it was the most
overwhelming feeling and you know how
great that was oh my God it was great
but that's the story of that but when
you sing that when we did the Academy of
Country Music Awards when you did that
at the end I mean to tell you that whole
crowd Whitney she would have been so
proud of you because I felt like she was
watching it you absolutely killed it
seriously it was incredible and I was so
emotional me too right now like I'm just
I know it hit me that you're like
talking about me singing it's fine well
it was great though no it was incredible
we're not they're saying can you do a
little no Iowa crowd no
how about
how about a boxing a little bit of it
you saying harmony with me okay okay
okay
[Music]
that break
s
it's the little things I don't know if
y'all heard it was like on will that
there's your breaks and your voice are
so magical you're like a magical fairy
human I don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]